Hello English learners from all over the world.
Chad here with another very cool English lesson
based on a really funny scene from Friends,
one of the best TV shows for learning English.
So to really make the most out of this learning
experience, download the Power Lesson.
There you are going to see that we break down
and explain all the most important vocabulary,
expressions, slang, also the pronunciation,
all the connected speech, and the cultural
references.
The stuff that doesn't translate very well.
So this is a really funny scene it's based
on Thanksgiving.
You may see Joey Tribianni eat a whole turkey
too, so sit back, relax, prepare yourself
for this learning experience, and enjoy
this scene from Friends.
Aww yeah!!